>>Be careful.
I don't want you to think that I'm
saying that lecturing is wrong.
There's a place for all
different modes of instruction.
>>Narrator: For decades,
America's schools
of education have spent
countless hours lecturing students
on teaching theory, leaving
many of them ill prepared
for the realities they'll
face in today's classrooms.
Today, prospective teachers are
learning as much from working
with students as they are from
working with college professors.
And in places like the University
of Virginia's Curry School program,
they will graduate
with a solid grounding
in their academic subject
matter, and the teaching know how
to make concepts like the Doppler
effect come alive in the classroom.
>>Now what I wanna do is toss it
around the room, and I want you folks
to notice the sound
as it's approaching
or going away from you, all right?
Don't hurt anybody.
>>I wanted there to be an
opportunity for students
to experience the phenomena
in a classroom.
They have a basic understanding of
their content or their subject area.
They're pretty green when it comes
to knowing how to teach that.
And I wanted to model how
you could start something
that really engages students.
>>Students: [applause, laughter]
>>Teacher: We were trying to look
at if we could make mold grow.
>>Narrator: At Curry, students
get into real classrooms
with real kids, early and often.
Sophomore year is generally
limited to observing in classrooms.
Later in the program, students get
involved in one on one tutoring.
>>And try doing file, quit,
and see if that works.
>>Narrator: They also develop
and present some class lessons
before honing their teaching skills
as full time student teachers.
>>I want you guys to
think of a person
who you think exemplifies you know,
you like the way they present--
they're a good actor or actress,
or they're a good speaker.
>>It looks so easy, until
you get in there and do it,
and then you're like,
"Whoa, this is so hard."
I mean, getting ready for
a lesson, hours go into it.
Classroom management, I
mean, that is a huge issue.
>>When you present information,
that presents information--
>>Mary: There's nothing like
walking into a classroom of twenty,
twenty five, thirty active students
and you've got to teach them.
And the first thing you've
got to do is to be able
to manage the classroom, because
if you can't manage a classroom,
you're not gonna teach
very much of anything.
And the second thing you've gotta do
is to be able to present the lesson
in a way that the children
understand they can learn
and they'll want to learn.
There's no place to do that better
than to actually be in a classroom
with a group of students.
>>Need to decide which piece of
artwork each person's gonna do
and then who's gonna
do the biography.
>>You find that picture
that you wanted.
>>Narrator: Kindergarten teacher,
Virginia Coffey, serves as a mentor
for Curry students like Alexa Kane.
Coffey graduated from
Curry before it began
to emphasize early classroom
exposure, which, she feels,
is essential for success.
>>It's a very sink
or swim profession,
and so I think it's valuable
that Curry has chosen to put them
in earlier and give them more
exposure over a period of time.
>>How much time do lawyers get and
how much time to medical doctors get
to work under supervision?
But I think it's the same in anything
you do, where the more you do it,
the better you get
because of that experience.
>>All: Run, run, as fast as you can.
You can't catch me, I'm
the gingerbread man.
>>Kenny, if you weren't so
dumb, we'd be done by now.
>>Calm down, Leon.
Just 'cause you did all the work
on this assignment doesn't
mean you're better than us.
>>Narrator: To extend actual
classroom experiences,
Curry uses multimedia technology
to offer the next best
thing, virtual classrooms.
>>Don't forget to work
on your project.
>>Narrator: Developed by
Curry faculty members,
CaseNEX presents case studies
of teaching situations,
combining video recreations,
comments by experts
and video conferencing
capability, delivered online.
>>Okay, Edith, what's up?
>>There have been several
reports about your unwillingness
to use the technology that's
available to you for your class.
Now to some parents,
that's very important.
>>I have too much to teach now to try
and incorporate video
games and the internet--
>>If I look at this
and I say, "Yikes!
This is something I might have to
deal with while I'm out there,"
then I'm gonna give it my all.
And so we're trying to prepare
people, edge them a little bit closer
to what it's really like out there,
and up their chances
for being successful.
>>CaseNEX allows diverse groups
of students to share their views
on common teaching dilemmas.
>>I don't know.
There's these two sides to that
issue, so what do you think of that?
>>For this case, a Curry class links
up with students at
Hampton University.
>>We set up the video conferencing
camera and using iVisit,
we saw each other online.
>>Okay, I agree with
what your student said.
>>I thought that was really
interesting, being that--
>>Then we brought up some of
the things that we really wanted
to delve deeper into and challenge
each other's ideas on more.
>>The first time I saw that case
got my mind working overtime.
>>When you're able to take a look
at another culture, another school,
another neighborhood, much easier.
And form partnerships with people
through the Internet and email,
that opened lines of communication
that haven't been open before.
>>One of our students has commented.
Is this a good time for
me to share her comment?
>>Please do.
>>As the technology becomes
more commonplace in society,
I think more people will be
talking frankly with each other
and that's got to improve, both
teaching and learning and society.
>>Narrator: With the
combination of technology training
and early classroom exposure,
Curry is helping promising
teacher candidates achieve their
full potential.
>>I know you all have the
potential to be the kind of teacher
that can change students' lives
and make students enjoy subjects
that they never thought
they could enjoy,
or that they could
have success in before.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org